ASSEMBLY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE HEARING WE ARE
CONTINUING TO REQUIRE THE MAST
BE WORN BY EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM
AND INSIDE THE BUILDING IF YOU
DO NOT HAVE A MASK WE CAN
PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU WE HAVE A
FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR
WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY. FOR THE
PUBLIC TO READ DO NOT HAVE THE
EXTRA ROOM TODAY TO TESTIFY
HOWEVER YOU CAN DIAL IN. WE'RE
USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH ANY
WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL
THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE IS.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN. YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS
WELL AS ON YOUR TV SCREEN. IF
YOU'RE CALLING IN PLEASE DO SO
WHEN THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
YOU'RE ESTIFYING ON BEGINS WITH
THE BILL PRESENTATION WE ONLY
HAVE ONE FROM MY UNDERSTANDING.
THE OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL
GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO
BE PLACE IN THE QUEUE. IF YOU
ARE CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE
ALL BACKGROUND NOISE THIS
INCLUDES MUTING YOUR LIVESTREAM
BROADCAST ON AND YOUR SMART-
DEVICES. PLEASE NOTE IF YOU'RE A
PRIMARY WITNESS PROVIDING
TESTIMONY YOU WILL REMAIN ON A
LIFELINE- NEED TO ROOT YOUR
DEVICE UNTIL YOUR CALL IN TO
SPEAK. IF YOU'RE HAVING PROBLEMS
WITH THE PHONE SERVICE PLEASE
CALL THE COMMITTEE ROOM AT NINE
ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE. THREE
NINE. FIVE EIGHT. MY STUFF WILL
BE THERE TO HELP YOU. WE ASO
ACCEPT WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH
THE POSITION LOW VOTER PORTAL ON
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. THANK
YOU FOR BEARING WITH US. WITH US
AS WE CONTINUE USING METHODS TO
SERVE THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
WHILE ALSO BEING MINDFUL AND
RESPECTFUL OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERNS. WE STILL FACE. NOW
LET'S JUST COVER A FEW THE
GROUND RULES AND I THINK WE'RE
GONNA BE FINE TODAY BUT
APPROPRIATE CONDUCT HERE.
ASSEMBLY HAS EXPERIENCED A
NUMBER OF DISRUPTIONS TO
COMMITTEES OF FLOOR PROCEEDINGS
IN THE PAST. CONDUCT THAT
DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE
IMPEDE THE ORDER- OR THE CONDUCT
OF THE HEARING IS PROHIBITED.
THE AND SUCH CONDUCT RAN CLUED
REMOVING AMASSED TALKING WITH-
AND LOUDLY UTTERING LOUD
THREATENING VOICES. AND ANY
OTHER DESTRUCTIVE ACTS. TO
ADDRESS THIS I WILL TAKE FIVE
WILL TAKE STEPS OF MAKING SURE
OUR HEARING PROCESS WILL GO
SMOOTHLY. AND WE WILL BE WARNING
PEOPLE IF WE HAVE CONTINUED
DISRUPTIONS. IF THE CURRENT
CONDUCT DOES NOT STOP- REQUEST
ASSISTANCE BY THE SWORD
SERGEANTS. SO WE ONLY HAVE ONE
ITEM TODAY ON THE AGENDA WE WILL
TAKE UP TO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. I BELIEVE WE DO HAVE
ONE AND UP TO TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION I DON'T
HAVE ANY SHOWING AT THIS POINT.
ARE THESE WITNESSES WILL HAVE
THREE MINUTES EACH TO PROVIDE
THEIR TESTIMONY ALL SUBSEQUENT
WITNESSES SHALL STATE THEIR NAME
THEIR ORGANIZATION AND THE
POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY. ALSO
THIS AFTERNOON I'D LIKE TO THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VINCE FONG WHO
WILL BE STANDING IN FOR SOME
REMEMBER RECALL RANDY VOEPEL WHO
IS ABSENT TODAY. AND WELCOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG- LET'S SEE
WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM BUT-
WHERE WE DO THERE WE GO SO US
SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE DO THE
ROLE. CURRY HI ARE HERE YEAH WE
ARE CREATED HERE LASKY. BLOOM
WHEN HERE HER MORE ABOUT FONG
YOUR PHONE HERE. RAMOS
THREE OF US THREE OF US
ROBERT RIVAS. RE A QUORUM THANK
YOU VERY MUCH IN OUR SINGLE BILL
ON TODAY'S AGENDA IS SB FOUR
EIGHTEEN BY SENATOR LAYERED
SENATOR. PLEASE JOIN US IN
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK. HOW'S THAT THANK YOU- GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS SO
I CHAIRED A LOT OF HEARINGS IN
THIS ROOM IT'S DISORIENTING TO
PRESENTING SENATE BILL FOR
EIGHTEEN THAN BEFORE I BEGIN LET
ME DO TWO THINGS FIRST I WILL
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
THAT ARE LISTED ON PAGE SEVEN OF
THE CAN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
AND I WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR
AND HER STAFF FOR ALL THE EFFORT
THAT WENT TO THAT PREVIOUS
SENTENCE HER BECAUSE IT WAS
GREAT AND I THINK WE
ACCOMPLISHED WHAT WE- WE NEEDED
TO DO HERE I ALSO WANT TO THANK-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. ROBERT RIVAS
AND- ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARK STONE
AND CENTER ON A COPPER GYRO
THEY'RE ALL CO AUTHORS IN THEIR
ANYBODY THAT CURRENTLY OR HAS
REPRESENTED THE PAPAROA VALLEY
DID UNDERSTANDS HOW IMPORTANT.
THIS ISSUE IS. IN IT'S BASED ON
THE FACT THAT IN NOVEMBER OUR
AREA WAS ROCKED BY THE FACT THAT
. THE HEDGE FUND THAT OWNS THE
WATSONVILLE HOSPITAL ANNOUNCED
THAT THEY WERE GOING TO CLOSE IT
IN TWO WEEKS AND ISSUED LAYOFF
NOTICES TO ALL THE EMPLOYEES.
THERE ARE SIX HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE EMPLOYEES. TWENTY FIFTY TWO
HUNDRED PHYSICIANS AND IT REALLY
IS THE BASIC MEDICAL CARE FOR
THE PAPAROA VALLEY WHICH
CROSSES. ARE COUNTY LINES INTO
NORTHERN MONTEREY AND INTO
WATSON FILM. I AM NOT IHAVE
FOUND IN MY EXPLANATIONS I'VE
SAID THIS IS A DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY. BUT YOU'LL SEE IN THE
BILL THAT IT OVERLAPS THE
DISTRICT THAT IS SET UP OVERLAPS
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT AND THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT HAS 35% ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS. AND ARE
EIGHTY PER CENT OF FREE AND
REDUCED UNDUPLICATED MALES IN
THE SCHOOL SYSTEM THAT IS JUST A
STATEMENT ABOUT. OF THE LEVEL OF
THIS AREA AND WHAT THIS HOSPITAL
SERVES. IN DECEMBER FORMAL
BANKRUPTCY WAS ARE DECLARED
UNFORTUNATELY A PART TIME JOB AT
THE BANKRUPTCY GOES. WITH A
TARGET OF BEING FINALIZED RIGHT
AT THE END OF MARCH AND
NEGOTIATIONS WERE DONE AND THE
FIRST RIGHT OF PURCHASE WAS
GRANTED. TO A LOCAL COMMUNITY
GROUP WHICH IS THE PAPAROA
VALLEY HEALTH CARE DISTRICT
PROJECT AND IT WAS CREATED BY
THE COUNTY OF SANTA CRUZ THE
CITY OF WATSONVILLE. SLOUGH
PRADAL HENTAI WHICH IS THE LONG
STANDING NONPROFIT CLINICS
SERVING OF FARMWORKERS AND OTHER
PEOPLE IN THE PROPER OF OUR AND
THE COMMUNITY HEALTH. TRUST OF
THE PAPAROA FAMILY. AND SO. THIS
BILL. THE HOSPITAL DISTRICT THAT
WILL ALLOW THAT GROUP TO MOVE
AHEAD WITH THE PURCHASE OF THE
HOSPITAL. AND THIS BILL IS
URGENTLY NEED THE BIDS ARE DUE
ON FEBRUARY THIRTEENTH AND
THAT'S WHY THERE'S AN URGENCY
MEASURE HERE. AND THAT'S WHY WE
TOOK SOME STEPS IN FORMING THE
DISTRICT THAT REFLECT ABERDEEN
CITY. ESTABLISHED THAT THERE
WILL BE AN ELECTED BOARD OF
DIRECTORS AND THERE WILL BE
DISTRICTS BUT THE COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS TO APPOINT THE
GOVERNMENT'S OUT THE BATCH SO
THAT THEY CAN GET IT OFF THE
GROUND IN THE TIME THAT THEY
HAVE TO DO AND THEN THE
ELECTIONS WILL COME LATER. IT
SPECIFIES THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
MINUS THE AREA OF APTOSE. AS THE
DISTRICT FOR THE HOSPITAL AND
THAT'S SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE IT
CROSSES BOTH SIDES AND THE BEEN
IN DISCUSSIONS WITH BOTH LAUGH
CODES ON EACH SIDE LOCAL AGENCY
FORMATION COMMISSION. IN WHICH
THEY RECOGNIZE THE URGENCY AND
THERE'S AN AGREEMENT THAT IF
EITHER LAUGH CO HAS AN ISSUE
WITH THE DISTRICT BOUNDARY OVER
TIME IT WILL BE REVISITED BUT
THIS WILL ALLOW IT TO MOVE AHEAD
WITH THE URGENCY. OF THAT. WE
SEE. AN THE TIME OF THE DAY
ALLOWS FOR THAT PURCHASE- TO
HAPPEN AND THE BID IS BEING
PREPARED AND SO. THE AMENDMENTS
THAT ARE ACCEPTED AT THE
BEGINNING ADDRESS A NUMBER OF
CONCERNS THAT CAME. FROM THIS
COMMITTEE AND FROM THE COMMITTEE
IN THE SENATE BECAUSE THIS IS A
AN AMENDMENT ON THIS SIDE AND
AMENDMENTS CAN'T BE TAKEN IN THE
SENATE BECAUSE WE TRYING TO
CONCUR AND GET IT TO THE
GOVERNOR IN A TIMELY FASHION.
AND SO. THE AMENDMENT BASICALLY
THAT THIS HOSPITAL. IF IT'S SOLD
THE DISTRICT DISSOLVES. ARM AND
- OF. NOT A MISSING THE OTHER
ONE BUT THE BASIC ISSUE HERE IT
OFF IT'S NOT REALLY DELIVERING
SERVICES IF IT WILL BE SOLD AS
WELL SO IT PROTECTS AGAINST WHAT
THE CONCERNS WERE IN OTHER
HOSPITAL DISTRICTS IN THE STATE
AND IF THERE'S A REQUIREMENT FOR
ANY REPORTS OF ANY KIND ARE WE
WILL WE ARE COMMITTED TO DO A
FOLLOW UP BILL THAT ARE A DOES
DOES BECAUSE WE NEED TO MOVE
THIS WITH THE URGENCY. TO ALLOW
THI DISTRICT TO BE IN TO OUR
PLOY SO WITH ME TODAY AND YOU'LL
SEE IN THE ANALYSIS THAT THIS
BILL WAS ONLY AMENDED LAST
FRIDAY AND THERE ARE ALREADY
TWENTY MAJOR SIGNIFICANT
ENTITIES IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
IT REPRESENTS UNITY ACROSS THE
REGION AND ONE OF THE HOSPITALS
TO SOLDER IN. ANOTHER PART IN
SUPPORT OF HERE. AND I THINK
EVERY UNDERSTANDS THAT THIS IS A
KEY PART OF HEALTHCARE DELIVERY
IN THE AREA THAT IF THIS
HOSPITAL WENT UNDER. IT WOULDN'T
JUST BE THAT SIX HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE PEOPLE WOULD BE
UNEMPLOYED. IT WOULD BE THAT-
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WOULD NOT BE
RECEIVING PRIMARY HOSPITAL
HEALTH CARE. AND THERE ARE SOME
NUANCES TO OUR WHICH IS THAT
KAISER HAS COME INTO OUR AREA IN
THE LAST SEVEN RIGHT HERE'S- AND
THEY'RE ONLY ALLOWED TO DO THEIR
OUT PATIENT CLINICS. BECAUSE
THEIR PHYSICIANS HAVE PRIVILEGES
AT WATSONVILLE HOSPITAL. SO IT
FITS TOGETHER WITH EVERYTHING
ELSE SEVERAL. I KNOW THAT THERE
WAS. ARE YOU CONCERNED ABOUT HOW
FAST THIS WAS MOVING IT HAS TO
MOVE THIS FAST FOR THIS TO
HAPPEN SO THE ONE WITNESS I HAVE
HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT IS MIMI
HOME TH CHAIR OF THE PAPAROA
VALLEY HEALTH CARE DISTRICT
PROJECT BOARD OF DIRECTORS AND
IT'S VERY SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE
SHE WAS THE COUNTY HEALTH
SERVICES DIRECTOR. UNTIL A
COUPLE OF MONTHS AGO IN SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY AND I THINK THE
CHAIR KNOWS ARE FROM THE YOLO
COUNTY HEALTH DEPARTMENT WHICH
IS ONE PLACE WHERE SHE WAS
BEFORE SHE CAME TO OUR REGION SO
I APPRECIATE THAT THEN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIFLE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
ALERT I'D LIKE TO ASK THE
OPERATOR TO OPEN THE LINE FOR
OUR WITNESS AND SUPPORT ME HALL
. ME ME WHEN YOU'RE READY PLEASE
BEGIN. HERE GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MEGAN HALL AND I'M THE CHAIR OF
THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF THE
POWER OF VALLEY HEALTH CARE
DISTRICT PROJECT. WE ARE THE
SPONSORS THAT SENATOR THERE
SENATE BILL FOR EIGHTEEN WHICH
WOULD CREATE A HER OVERLY
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT IN SANTA
CRUZ AND MONTEREY COUNTY. FOR
THE PURPOSES OF TAKING OWNERSHIP
OF WATSONVILLE COMMUNITY
HOSPITAL TO AVOID AN IMMINENT
CLOSURE AND ENSURE THAT OUR
HOSPITAL REMAINS OPEN TO THE
COMMUNITY. AS THEIR DEMENTIA THE
WHAT TALKING HOSPITAL THE ONE.
SIX THAT HOSPITAL IT IS CRUCIAL
TO THE RESIDENTS OF SANTA CRUZ
MONTEREY AND CARMEL VALLEY. THE
HOSPITAL PROVIDES A WIDE RANGE
OF QUALITY MEDICAL SERVICES
INCLUDING EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT
SERVICES. A STEP CHECKS AND DATA
QUALITY PEDIATRICS MEDICAL
SURGICAL CARE ORTHOPEDICS
CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE CARE YOUR
METHODOLOGY AND MORE. IT IS ONE
OF ONLY TWO HOSPITALS IN SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY WITH AN EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT AND IN TWENTY TWENTY
WHAT THE BILL COMMUNITY HOSPITAL
TO DELIVER THE VAST MAJORITY OF
BABIES IN THE COUNTY OVER ANY
OTHER FACILITY. SERVING A
SIGNIFICANT IMMIGRANT POPULATION
THE HOSPITAL PROVIDE CARE TO
THOSE WHO WITHOUT ENGLISH
ENGLISH LANGUAGE PROFICIENCY IN
THEIR PREFERRED LANGUAGE. AND
NEARLY HALF OF THE HOSPITAL
PATIENTS ARE A MEDIC CAL. HER
VALLEY THE LARGEST COMMUNITY OF
THE CITY OF WATSONVILLE WHICH IS
A STARK WE FACED MANY HEALTH AND
ECONOMIC PROSPERITY LONG BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC. AFTER THE PANDEMIC
LIKE MANY COMMUNITY WE
EXPERIENCED LOSS OF EMPLOYMENT
SCHOOL CLOSURES. AND NON
ESSENTIAL WORKERS. WHO WERE
REQUIRED TO STAY AT HOME.
OVERCROWDED IN THAT STANDARD CAN
. FOOD AND LACK OF
TRANSPORTATION AND THE HIGH COST
OF HOUSING INTENSIFIED
DISPARITIES OVERNIGHT. THE
CURRENT VALLEY HAS SEEN DRAMATIC
IN DISPROPORTIONATE RATES OF
COVERT NINETEEN INSPECTION WHICH
I THOUGHT DURING MY TIME AT%
HEALTH SERVICES AGENCY DIRECTOR
AND INCIDENT COMMANDER OF THE
COOK AT NINETEEN RESPONSE. IT
ALSO HAD HIGHER HOSPITALIZATION
AND DEATH- TO THE REST OF SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY. AS A FORMER COUNTY
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS I HAVE
SEEN FIRST HAND THE IMPORTANCE
OF WATSONVILLE COMMUNITY
HOSPITAL. IN PROVIDING TIMELY
ACCESS TO CARE ADDRESSING HEALTH
DISPARITIES FACED CUTTING THE
HEALTH OF ALL IN OUR COMMUNITY.
THE HOSPITAL HAS BEEN ESSENTIAL
IN SERVING OUR PRIMARILY LOW
INCOME UNDER AND UNINSURED
POPULATIONS OF COLOR COLOR FOR
OVER A CENTURY AND HAS BEEN
CRUCIAL IN SERVING THOSE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
KOPET. HOSPITAL DOES HAVE A
HISTORY OF FINANCIAL CHALLENGES.
UNDER COSTLY PRIVATE EQUITY
OWNERSHIP AND WHILE THE
COMMUNITY IS DISCUSS PUBLIC
OWNERSHIP FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS.
THE INCIDENT LATE LAST YEAR ON
THANKSGIVING WEEK WHEN THE
CURRENT OWNER OPERATOR SENT TO
WARN NOTICES ALL OF ITS
EMPLOYEES ANNOUNCING ITS
INTENTION TO FILE FOR BANKRUPTCY
AND RELEASETHEM ON JANUARY IN
JANUARY. AT WAS. THE IMPETUS FOR
US TO MOVE FORWARD. THE CURRENT
OWNER OPERATORS FILED FOR
CHAPTER ELEVEN BANKRUPTCY
PROTECTION. IN OUR ORGANIZATION
IMMEDIATELY BEGAN NEGOTIATIONS
WITH THE CURRENT OWNER OPERATOR
SO THAT WE COULD PURCHASE THE
HOSPITAL THROUGH THE BANKRUPTCY
PROCEEDING. BECAUSE SHE SIMPLY
RESULTED IN AN ASSET PURCHASE
AGREEMENT WITH THE OWNER
OPERATOR AND WE HAVE ESTABLISHED
OURSELVES THE PROJECT AS THE
PRIORITY BETTER. AND AN ISSUE
THE PROCESS FOR THE YET TO BE
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICT
TO TAKE OVER THE HOSPITAL
OPERATION. ADDITIONALLY THE
CURRENT OWNER OPERATOR AND ITS
LARGEST CREDITORS HAVE AGREED TO
DEFER CLOSURE OF THE HOSPITAL
AFTER MARCH ALLOWING US TIME TO
GO THROUGH THIS PROCESS. THE
FORMATION OF A NEW HEALTH CARE
DISTRICTS THROUGH THIS
LEGISLATION IS REQUIRED AS KEY
MILESTONES IN OUR PROJECT ASSET
PURCHASE AGREEMENT FILED AS PART
OF THE FEDERAL. CHAPTER ELEVEN
BANKRUPTCY COURT PROCESS. THE
PROJECT STRONGLY BELIEVES THAT
PUBLIC OWNERSHIP THEIR
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT OFFERS THE
MOST PROMISING FUTURE FOR WHAT
THE BILL COMMUNITY HOSPITAL. AND
FOR NOT JUST CONTINUING BUT
IMPROVING HEALTHCARE ACCESS
THROUGHOUT THE HOME VALLEY. WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS A HIGHLY
UNUSUAL REQUEST AND WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION WITH
COMMITTEE CHAIR AND STAFF ABOUT
ADDITIONAL ACCOUNTABILITY AS WE
MOVE FORWARD. I ASSURE YOU THAT
WE TAKE SERIOUSLY OUR COMMITMENT
TO ENSURING ACCESS TO CARE IN
OUR COMMUNITY AND BELIEVE THAT
THE PATH THAT WE'RE ON IT THE
BEST WAY TO PROCEED. GIVEN THE
VERY CHALLENGING TIME CONSTRAINT
OF THE CHAPTER ELEVEN PROCESS.
WITH THIS INFORMATION WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE ON SB FOUR EIGHTEEN THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISS HALL- ARE
THERE ANY OTHER- PRINCIPAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. ALL RIGHT THERE'S NONE
ACCORDING TO THE SENATOR ARE
THERE ANY PRINCIPLE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. I DO NOT SEE ANYONE
HERE IN THE HALL. SO WE'RE GOING
TO ASSUME THERE ISN'T ANYONE
WILL OPEN THE PHONE LINES RIGHT
NOW FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
SIMPLY YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND IF YOU SUPPORT.
OR OPPOSE SO DO BOTH SUPPORT AND
OPPOSE ONE TIME TODAY. OPERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THAT UP THE LINES.
GERMAN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT ON
TODAY'S UP LEGISLATION PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME
. IT WILL START WITH LINE FORTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS SOMATIC BROUGHT ON
BEHALF OF THE TEAMSTERS IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER. NEXT WE GO TO
LINE THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU AMBER KING WITH
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT HERE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER.
MEXICO LINE THIRTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ASSEMBLY HILLARY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANKS SO
MUCH THANK YOU NEXT CALL. NEXT
TO GO TO LINE THIRTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS JEAN HURST CALLING
IN TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
OF SANTA CRUZ AND THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER. SHE GOT
A LINE THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS ASHLEY WALKER WITH
KNOCKED AND THEN ON BEHALF OF
THE MONTEREY COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT. THANKYOU NEXT CALLER. MEXICO TO LINE
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THE
ENTRY JAMES CALLING ON THE
BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY HEALTH
TRUST THE POWER VALLEY IN
SUPPORT OF BETH BEFORE EIGHTEEN
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER
. MEXICO LINE FORTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT
WAS A ABOUT THE AS YET YOU
CALIFORNIAN IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER. MEXICO LINE
FORTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
ANTHONY CANNOT WITH CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER. BUT NEXT TO A LINE FORTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS TRENT SMITH ON
BEHALF OF THE CENTRAL COAST
ALLIANCE FOR HELP SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. NEXT CALLER. AND MADAM
CHAIR THERE'S NO OTHERS IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- OPERATOR- ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
YES SEEING NONE- ENTERTAIN A
MOTION. OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALMOST A SECOND
BUYER ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS. AND WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE JUST SET THIS- WILL
PROVIDE ACCESS TO HEALTH
SERVICES FOR EVERYONE IN THE
PARK ABOUT I WOULD APPRECIATE
YOUR AYE VOTE AND THANK YOU FOR
THE CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU FOR
PRESENTING TODAY- CENTER
LEARNING FOR WORKING CLOSELY
WITH ME IN THE COMMITTEE. ALSO
THANK YOU FOR ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN
THE ANALYSIS. I UNDERSTAND THE
DIRE NEED FOR THIS HOSPITAL STAY
OPEN AND RECOGNIZE HOW IMPORTANT
THESE HOSPITAL SERVICES ARE TO
YOUR YOURS AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RIVAS IS MUTUAL. CONSTITUENTS
THIS COMMITTEE AND I HAVE A LONG
HISTORY WITH HEALTH CARE
DISTRICTS ESPECIALLY ON THE
ISSUE PROVIDING. DIRECT HEALTH
CARE SERVICES. WE'VE DISCUSSED
MY CONCERNS THAT THERE IS NO
GUARANTEE THAT THE DISTRICT WLL
ACQUIRE THE HOSPITAL. AND THAT
MANY HEALTH CARE DISTRICTS HAVE
STRUGGLED TO KEEP THEIR
HOSPITALS OPEN IN THE PAST. THE
MEMBERS PROVIDE PROTECTIONS TO
THE LOCAL COMMUNITY AND ENSURE
THE INTENT OF THIS DISTRICT AS A
HOSPITAL SERVICE. PROVIDER TO
MEAN TO IS MAINTAINED MAINTAINED
OR THE HEALTH CARE DISTRICT WILL
BE DISSOLVED. I HAVE HAVE A
CONCERN WITH BY PASSING THE
LOCAL LEFT GO PROCESS WHICH
EXISTS TO ALLOW FOR ROBUST
PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT. I ASK THAT
YOU CONTINUE WORKING ON
REQUIREMENTS TO ALLOW FOR THE
LOCAL OFFICE TO MONITOR THE
DISTRICT INTO STAYING GAUGED AND
AGAIN SENATOR THANK YOU FOR
WORKING SO CLOSELY WITH US AND
WITH THE AMENDMENTS I WILL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY.
MOTION IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AGUIAR-CURRY HI AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
LACKEY. LACKEY I BLOOM. BLOOM I
BOERNER HORVATH. BOERNER HORVATH
HI FONG. FONG I RAMOS RAMOS AYE
THREE OF US THREE OF US AYE
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS I.
ZERO EIGHT ZERO- THANK YOU OF
THE SENATOR AND- KIND I HOPE
THIS IS REALLY SUCCESSFUL FOR
YOUR CONSTITUENTS I LOOK FORWARD
TO HEARING HOW THIS GOES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ALL. WE CAN
ADJOURN THE MEETING ANNA YAHOO.